[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
européen vous ne pouvez pas dire que
vous n'avez pas vu ce qui est arrivé aux
ukrainiens à marioupol aux habitants de
marioupol vous avez vu vous savez les
bombardements aériens sont intenses
et vienne frappées cet hôpital
pédiatrique
c'est odieux et c'est cruel et tragique
et je condamne ça avec la plus grande
vigueur je suis convaincu que ça ça peut
être un crime de guerre il est atroce de
voir ce genre d'utilisation
barbare de la force militaire contre des
civils innocents dans un pays souverain
les femmes enceintes et le personnel
avaient été évacués de la maternité
on sait depuis trois jours que cet
hôpital était devenue une base du ultra
radicaux de néo-nazis et frappe de la
russie contre l'hôpital pédiatrique de
marioupol sont inhumaines et lâche
l'opinion publique est manipulé le point
de vue des russes n'est jamais prise en
compte être fasciné par la force la
force d'hitler là la force de poutine
c'est dire que poutine est un démocrate
comme vous l'avez encore fait il ya
quelques jours c'est dire que poutine et
l'agressé pas l'agresseur c'est dire que
poutine il faut un putin français notre
armée à des ordres très précis de ne pas
cibler les installations civiles
ou presque malheureusement les
nationalistes ukrainiens sont capables
de telles actions quand on est sous
influence de poutine on veut pas dire
patriotes et c'est pour cela monsieur
zemmour que vous êtes décrédibilisés
pour présider la france les 27 chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de l'union
sont réunis en ce moment même et jusqu'à
demain à versailles plus de 500 millions
d'euros ont été débloqués pour
accueillir des réfugiés ukrainien 500
autres millions vont être consacrés à
l'achat de matériel militaire ensuite il
ya la question de savoir si la russie va
un moment donné faire pression et
utiliser larmes du gaz président poutine
s'est exprimé tout à l'heure pour dire
que la russie continuerait à fournir
jusqu au camp en fonction de quoi nul ne
sait c'est ça une dépendance une
vulnérabilité et donc nous devons nous
préparer à tous les scénarios un jour
vous êtes pour lutter contre le grand
remplacement le lendemain vous dites que
quand emplacement n'existe pas un jour
vous manifester contre le mariage
homosexuel et puis quelques années après
vous nous dites waouh nomme en fait
c'était très bien avouer c'est un autre
pas dû vous parlera du tout pas du tout
cas pas du tout quand allez-vous vous
prononcer sur votre soutien
un petit indice lâchez moi un petit truc
si vous préférez en vérité vous n'êtes
qu'une technocrates in gestionnaire
alors la politique vous échappe parce
que la politique c'est avoir des
convictions que vous trahissez sans
cesse depuis quinze ans candidat
emmanuel macron cette fois entend
repousser l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans s'il est réélu
effectivement dans le programme d'
emmanuel macron il y aura la proposition
d'allonger
l'âge de départ à la retraite et donc de
le passer progressivement à 65 ans à 65
ans alors nous avons un désaccord
absolue d'accord lui pour la retraite à
65 ans moi je suis pour la retraite à 60
ans moi je réintroduit les critères de
pénibilité
je garantis la retraite à 62 ans je ne
change pas tous les deux
je ne
sais pour qui vous votez au moins
vous appellera à voter pour les malades
manquerait ce qu'est ce que j'attendais
pour venir à béziers mais d un petit que
moi si je vais à béziers alors déjà que
ma réputation est faite et là ça va
vous arrangerez pas mes affaires il ya
plus de gouvernement parce que c'est au
conseil de défense qui tu prend ses
décisions il ya plus d'assemblée
nationale parce que c'est suspendu cet
homme a les pleins pouvoirs et ça vous
fait rien du tout vous êtes 30% dire à
quelle bonne idée on va lui faire encore
confiance en gp2 en isère où on va
[Musique]